how are you guys doing
it's so good to see you i haven't seen
you in a while uh yes i think something
in a while but here we are right exactly
so i want to start with
uh and i mean this 2020 has been a
disaster
and it was really a lot of fun to watch
like a feel-good family movie last night
so just want to throw that out there i
think people are really going to enjoy
it
thank you steven um before i ask you
some specific questions about the movie
i know that you guys have been
getting asked a lot of the same stuff so
i want to throw some curveballs but i
promise you they're
they're softballs there's nothing
hard-hitting here um i want to start
with the first thing being uh
for each of you uh is there a tv series
you would love to guest star on
oh that's fun my dream was always to do
curb
your enthusiasm and i did it and it was
as fantastic as
my wildest dreams and i played a
character that i've
like my favorite comic character of all
time um and i was really happy with how
it worked out
so i feel like i've done my bucket list
on that guy
i'm gonna pick i'm gonna pick snl
because then i would get to host and
i've never done it if i'm not mistaken
you were a writer on snl though
i was i was writer for a year right uh
yeah i can't even imagine what that was
like and by the way that
curb is an amazing show and uh
i i can't even imagine what that would
have been like to work with larry
just you know can't um is what movie do
you guys think you've seen the most
clue
oh gosh great what maybe that's a spinal
tap
okay great movies um my last uh
you know softball if you will um do you
remember your first movie or tv show
crush oh
yeah um
jason bateman and teen wolf too
um steven seagal
i i have so many things to say about
that but
yes you should um
which which movie was it hard to kill or
was it uh
um which of the two word titles or three
words one what's the navy one
under under siege under siege right
yeah got it got it i have so many things
to say
okay let's jump into let's jump into why
i get to talk to you guys um
when you guys signed on to do this this
was um when
disney plus i believe it only launched
for like a little while it only been
online for like
two three months when you guys agreed to
do it how much did you know about the
service
and what it was aiming to do when you
signed on
all the creative got brought up my
agent's like you've got it disney it's
all about disney plus
it was already like you know i guess an
amazing
you know everybody was very excited i
i hadn't heard anything but only because
i'm
i'm secretly 108 years old so
i didn't know about it and i thought
what is
what is this i thought it was a web
series
so i was on the way other side of this
um and then i was
told that it's the biggest thing on
planet earth and i was like oh
i'd love to do it
that's so funny um well what's funny is
when when when you guys made it it
obviously was a small service but now it
has like 70 something million
subscribers it's like is it kind of
refreshing for the two of you
to have a movie coming out that is going
to be in 70 plus
million homes and not really have to
worry about like what does it do opening
weekend
yes that is the benefit of streamers all
the way i do have to say as someone
who's had a lot of
unlucky opening weekends let's just put
it that way not unlucky but like
the nerves around that and how it
impacts your business being seen in
you know something that's perceived as
either a failure or a hit um
yeah it's fantastic we'll we'll have a
good idea
yeah we're so lucky to be in a film like
this coming out
in this way um it just it takes the
pressure off
uh jumping into a specific did you want
to answer
no that was a great answer i'll leave it
at them
uh for each of you i am curious what was
it about
the story and the script that said i
really want to do this or was it also
just being part of a disney family movie
i've always wanted to play a witch um
i'm very vocal about that
i always heard me say this 18 times
today but i i want to play which i still
want to play which but this is the
closest i've ever
gotten to it and and because there's
spells and there's a wand and there's
magic
um but i uh when my man
he was like she was like you're gonna
want to do this like this is the closest
we're getting
so i beg my way into it got it
um and for me it was uh you know i i had
a window that i could work where my
house wasn't working and i could bring
the kids with me it was in boston
um and i really like is a female film
you know lady filmmaker
right written by woman a lot of females
in the story and in the you know the
the message was fantastic for you know
young kids a lot of these fairy tales
that we were told when we were young
don't
certainly aren't appropriate now whether
it be you know the trope of the knight
in shining armor or the
i don't know the evil stepmother that's
always a woman and you know all these
domestic
beautiful princesses that are just sort
of praised for being good and
subservient so it was like wow here we
go we're modernizing a fairy tale
um and this is a film that my you know
family can watch how exciting
yeah something else that i really found
refreshing about the movie is that
it doesn't have your like your typical
villain where someone's trying to get
your powers or
it's just you know it's just refreshing
uh you want to touch on that at all
yeah yeah go ahead no you really go
i just jumped in but i had nothing to
say i was panicked
i know i panicked too and i just started
um
you know i i don't have a lot to say
about it but i will say that
um i do think it's refreshing i think
it's nice that it's not like
some big scary villain is coming to get
us i mean in some cases i guess moira
wants to take me back but that's mostly
for for the good of
not losing my powers i will lose my
powers if i stay there for too long so
i do think that like with every
character there is some good
intention behind it which i actually
think is really cool
for for this type of a fairy tale
usually there's always some villain and
it's always a woman so it's
it's nice to have a um am i the villain
am i the villain in this oh you're no
baby you
no there's no villain in you i'm just
the miserable one i'm just
i'm the one that's still grieving my
husband and trying to
he's lost she's a little lost and she
needs some help for her fairy godmother
yeah i am a little curious uh how do you
prep to use the wand in a movie like
this
are you re-watching harry potter movies
and seeing how they did it
like what exactly is the the prep for
that what's funny is
i think i did exactly that i think i
youtubed like
harry potter and how they use it and i
was like okay just figure out your own
thing i might have
copied it i have no idea at this point
but i did get a
uh like a sample wand to bring back to
my hotel
and use it and i do feel like at one
point i left it out
and someone came in to bring room
service on late night when i hadn't
eaten anything
and i was like i never explained the
wand and it feels very odd that a 36
year old woman just has
a wand sitting on her desk
i think that's great though um for each
of you i've been asking
i've been talking to a lot of actors
over the last number of months and uh
one of the questions i've been asking
everyone
i want to ask you guys is do you
remember a day
on when you've worked on some project in
the past that you were
really nervous to film something and why
i was really nervous to film our opening
scene
actually on this um yeah i felt like i
just felt really it was just that
thing of like creating like a busy
office with deadlines and an annoying
boss
and but also to kind of not step on the
joke and i just felt like the tone of
the way we were introduced
felt at odds with the rest of the story
it felt too
heightened and i kind of but it but
anyway but we got there i think it got
edited it works desert the intro our
scene together our first scene together
100 okay great that that that i was
nervous about it's like
weirdly if you you because my car didn't
really have a point of view she was kind
of reactionary
to and i just had to sort of keep
getting information but um
and set up exposition for her to
continue giving a joke
and that's the tricky thing when you're
acting in a scene where you're
you're basically there is a tool right
for the other person to do something
rather than having an active
goal yourself um and uh but that's that
was the only scene in the movie that i
was nervous about
um really on this one i felt like
jillian and i
had a great rehearsal period of a week
where we were in a hotel room
and we had a laugh and we were just sort
of talking about our voices and
you know improvising stuff and so i felt
really safe with her
um i totally trusted julian right away
um and uh and i and i felt like we were
gonna have fun together and i feel like
we did
we did right julian yeah we did i i i
will say that i
um it was so nice to like you said be
able to trust the other person you're
working with because you have no idea
you know you're spending months with
this person and so it's so nice to feel
safe in that way but i do
i do feel very nervous and anxious often
especially on movie sets if there's you
know there was one scene where i'm
eating the donuts and i'm telling her
information and i'm kind of got a sugar
high so i'm
telling her a bunch of stuff very
quickly and i think some of it got cut
down but it was longer
and there was so much information to get
out at such a fast pace because i've
been eating these donuts
and that kind of thing makes me very
nervous so yeah i think i was nervous
before
that scene in particular i remember